of everybody or University of Copenhagen
and I'll talk about submodular
hospitable flow on trees it's a joint
work with Edina and Perry Nia who are
here at the workshop and also with
Andrews visa so let's start with the
definition of the problem in the
hospitable flower on tree problem we are
given an undirected three with
capacities on the address and were given
a collection of tasks for every task we
have a start vertex and an end vertex
meaning that a task response to some
puff in the tree and then we're given a
demand and profit and a feasible
solution is a subset of tasks that can
be simultaneously rooted in the tree
that is if we look at any a tree the
tree if we look at all the clothes and
tasks that are using this address then
their total demand does not exceed the
capacity of the edge and the goal is to
find a feasible solution maximizing the
profit and we can generalize this
problem to a sub modular and splittable
flow on trees when instead of linear
profit function we have sub modular
objective function so for any subset of
tasks the submodular function tells us
what is the profit of executing exactly
those tasks
and just a reminder for people who
haven't been here at the previous talk a
function is submodular if it satisfies
the following inequality for every two
sets a and B F of I plus F of B is at
least a intersection B plus F a union B
and we assume that the function is given
as a very Oracle that is we can ask what
is the value of the function for a given
subset and we get the answer and the
problem is np-hard or gadya when the
profits are in R and therefore most of
research focuses on approximation
algorithms and also another reminder and
alpha approximation algorithm is an
algorithm that again in polynomial time
and always outputs us a solution which
is within the alpha factor of the
optimal solution here the previous
results so when we have the inner
objective when our tree is just a path
we have constant factor approximation
and within our objective for arbitrary
tree we have log square n approximation
when we have a submodular objective we
have log and approximation for a path
and that's our result for for a tree
with path with K we have K log and
approximation for some modular you have
P where n is the number of vertices of
the tree and because every tree has path
we've at most log n that gives us log
square an approximation for arbitrary
trees which matters the same result for
in our objective functions and I'm not
sure how many of you know what path
width is so for those of you who don't
know what tough with is just think of K
as being clogged and is not crucial for
the talk so if someone knows what is
true if so path width is like to you
where are you where you require the tree
to be a path for those of you who don't
know what true it is drastic of it as
being Logan for the for the path case
okay
okay I think there's very little also
matters okay so that's the high level
idea of our approach so we will start
with an algorithm or Lin our objective
and polynomially bounded capacities and
this algorithm consists of a few steps
first we will get us our problem to
intersecting its answers and an
intersecting instance is an instance
where all the tops go through the root
of the tree and that's a standard step
which has been done before now we will
assume that we have an intersecting
instance and we will partition our tree
into a collection of facts and then for
every path we will consider a geometric
viewpoint that is not only we will care
about the fact that all the tasks have
to be routed via the path but also every
task will will be considered as a react
angle of where the height of the
rectangle is the demand and then we will
want to find a drawing of all the tasks
which will be routed via the given path
so that will add some additional
constraints to our problem and then with
this additional constraints we will
write an LP and then we will account
this LP using randomized grounding of
alteration that will give us an
algorithm in our objective and for
polynomially bounded capacities later we
will show how to remove the restriction
that the capacities are polynomially
bounded essentially instead of allowing
arbitrary to draw the rectangles in
arbitrary places will allow only to draw
rectangles as a limited number of places
and then we will show how to
standard to sub modular objective
function using contention resolution
scheme okay so we start with something
easy with an intersecting instance so
there's the following lemma saying that
why when we can when we lose a factor
log and women of the within the
approximation factor we can assume that
all the that all the tasks are cross
crossing the the root of the tree that
is that we have an intersecting instance
and this holds also when the objective
function that is the profit is sub
additive not only in our so it it holds
also for some modular cost functions and
the proof is very easy so I'll just show
it now we will partition the task into
logarithmic number of set such that each
set is a collection of independent
intersecting instances that's our tree
and in the first step which was the
center of the tree that is sat vertex
that in every sub tree here will have at
most half of the vertices and our first
instance will be all the tasks that used
the center of the tree and that's
clearly an intersecting instance and now
we know that none of the tasks are using
the gray edges here so now we have two
independent sub trees and again for any
of them which was the center again which
was all the paths that cross at least
that cross one of the center's that
gives us the second instance and so on
after a logarithmic number of steps
everything has been partitioned and here
we have a logarithmic number of
subproblems every sub-problem consists
of some independent a collection of
independent intersecting instances we
solve all of them we take the best one
so that will lose log and in the
approximation factor so to now to the
end of the talk we will assume that our
instance is intersecting
and now we will partition the tree into
paths so let us define an upward path in
a rooted tree we say that Apophis upward
if one of the endpoints of the path is
an ancestor of the other endpoint so
that's an example we have a tree and
every color corresponds to a path and
you can see that every path is an upward
path and we define a collection of paths
in a tree to be a kind of speaking even
every path is an upward paths the paths
partition the address of the tree and
when we look at any leaf of the tree and
the path going from the leaf to the root
it uses the address of at most K paths
so you can see that in the figure here
we have a 2 nice pleating because no
matter which path we take into account
it uses at most two colors and we can
show the following lemma that when we
have a tree of paths with K then we in
polynomial time we can construct and
know of kyanite speaking for the tree
the way we do it is as follows we start
with the with the address going down to
the roots and then we assign each of
them a unique color that is we assign we
start a unique path there and then we
proceed bottom-up when we when we
process and adds that that that all the
children have been colored we just
assign such a color that will minimize
the number of colors from the top from
the top vertex of the edge to all the
Leafs so here at the left it doesn't
matter for now whether we chose red or
green and here also the color doesn't
matter yet and for example when we color
now this ad you can see that it is best
to color it with color purple has done
all the paths will use at most two
colors and if instead we color two we've
color blue we would have a path with
three colors
so we continue and we get our kindness
feeding
how many colors do at most our paths
with so let's not show you our flock
okay
log on three yeah
maybe I won't go into any more details
there but after thinking about it first
short white seems I think it's luck and
exercise to try to find out that always
logon colors are enough for the tree and
in like binary tree of height log annual
needle organ colors
okay so now I will introduce the
geometric viewpoint so now we have the
rooted three and we have the partition
into the partition of the address into
upward paths and now for each path we
can think of it as an independent
instance of the problem where we project
all the tasks just on the one path so
for every task we look at which which
address of this particular path
our task is using and that's our
projection and it is easy to observe
that if all the address if all the tasks
are using the root of the tree and if
all the paths are upward paths it means
that all the stalks are using the
topmost edge all the tasks are using the
topmost edge of the path
and therefore without loss of generality
we can assume that the edge capacities
on the path are not increasing because
all the if a task starts somewhere here
it goes all the way to the to the top
the top now is on the left of the
picture so we can assume that when we
draw the capacity profile it will be a
one starter circuit one sided staircase
ok and now we will consider our tasks
and we will draw them as rectangles
below the capacity profile so as I'll
show you for every task which uses some
edges of the path we will draw a
rectangle where the height of the
rectangle is just the amount of the task
and the the length here will be exactly
the address of the path that the task is
using so every task will correspond to a
rectangle which starts at the very left
and continue somewhere and then it is
easy to observe that and the feasible
subset of the task has a representing
drawing that is we can we can draw the
rectangles underneath the capacity
profile so that no two of them are
overlapping and the way we do it we just
start with the task that is longest we
draw it at the bottom and then on the
top of it we draw we keep growing the
tasks and I think from the side from
this drawing is clear to see that if we
have a feasible solution it will never
exceed the capacity of the edges so now
based on this we will write an LP so we
have our tree we have an O of kindness
splitting and in the IP we will enforce
that for every path there's are you
presenting drawing so these are our
variables for each task I we have a
variable X I which is one if and only if
the task is in the solution and then if
the task is in the solution then for
every path which this task is using we
have to draw it as a certain height so
for each path of our splitting from each
task I which is present on this path and
for each height for which if we draw
this task at height H will not exceed
the
will not go beyond the capacity profile
we put a variable Y I HP which is one if
exactly the task corresponding the task
I at path P is drawn exactly at height H
and that's how our LP looks like okay
first we have the IP that that's how our
IP looks like we want to maximize the
the profit of our tasks that have been
scheduled for now we have in our cost
function later I will tell you how to
extend it to some modular and here we
have the constraint saying that if a
task has been scheduled than for every
path it has been drawn somewhere that is
for every path for every path and for
every task the sum the sum over all
Heights where the task has can be drawn
of the variables y equals x I okay that
means that every task that had been
scheduled is drawn somewhere and other
inequality tells us that if that the
corresponding correct angles are
non-overlapping that is for every path
and for every height there's at most one
rectangle which is active at this height
which gives us this following inequality
and now we will no relax it and get an
LP
now our variables X I and our variables
I Y can be between 0 and 1 and we can
around it in the following way
in the selection phase we will pick a
subset of tasks and determine a draw it
for them this will give us a solution
which is integral but might be
infeasible and then in the second step
will be alternation face we will pick a
subset of the selected tasks such that
the corresponding rectangles do not
overlap so how do we do this in the
first step is the selection phase where
remember that we want an integral
solution which might be infeasible so
here we fix a large constant C 1 and for
each task we add the task to the sub to
the collection of selected tasks
independently at random with probability
X I over C 1 K so now as will be the set
of selected tasks so now if we selected
the task we also need to select a place
to draw them so now for every task that
had been selected for every path such
that the task is active at this path we
need to choose the height and again we
do the simplest thing we just choose the
height independently at random according
to the probability distribution of the
variables Y from the LP
and that gives us a solution which might
be infeasible because of course maybe we
chose some rectangles which overlap so
now we have the second phase which is a
duration and here from this from the
subset of selected tasks we will choose
some tasks which will be accepted and
when we choose when we accept tasks will
ensure that there will be no overlapping
between the corresponding rectangles so
we will consider the paths in arbitrary
order and for each path we look at the
collection of selected tasks which are
active at this path and then we want to
choose a set of accepted tasks such that
they don't overlap on this what won't
happy how do we do this we order the
tasks in non increasing order according
to their demands so the the tallest
rectangles first and then we consider
the tasks and when we consider the tasks
we already we already have a fixed
height where we can add this task it's
only one particular height so what we do
is we just add this rectangle if we if
it doesn't overlap any other rectangle
which has previously been added if it
would overlap without added and that's
how we decide whether the task is
accepted on one particular path and then
our accepted tasks will be the tasks
that have been accepted for all the
paths and we can show the following we
can show that every selected task is
rejected with probability at most 1/2
how do we show it so first we show that
for any path P and for any task I which
is active at this path the probability
that the task is not accepted if it has
been selected is small how do we show it
that's quite easy because we have
ordered the tasks from the tallest task
today to the istel task so whenever we
add a task then if it overlaps some
tasks which
which has probably which has been added
before then either it's left top corner
must overlap this task or its left
bottom corner must overlap the task
because all the thoughts that have been
added before are taller and probability
of this happening is small because in
our LP we had the constraint that about
about how much and how many tasks we can
add which overlap one particular point
so because everything has been scaled
down by a factor 1 over C 1 ok that's
essentially the probability that a task
will not be accepted now because every
task is active at at most KY apps that
gives us dilemma that is each selected
task is rejected with probability at
most 1/2 that gives us a log and
approximation algorithm if we have in
our objective functions and if we have
polynomially bounded at capacities okay
so first I will tell you that shortly
how to remove restriction on edge
capacities so the problem is that if we
can't have exponential at capacities
then we have exponential number of
variables because then it could happen
that so then every task can be drawn we
have like exponential number of choices
of height where the task can be drawn
but we can show here that if we restrict
ourselves to some carefully chosen
polynomials set of heights then we still
get a solution which will which will
only be by a constant fraction words
from the optimal solution and here I
don't want to go into the details it's
quite technical so essentially we only
choose a polynomial number of heights
and then we side that there's a kind of
close to optimal solution which only
puts the rectangles at the given height
okay so now our last part some modular
objective functions so now I will
introduce some notation most of this has
been previewed has been present at the
previous lecture so we have a finite
ground set and which we can think of as
our tasks then we have a family of
subsets which we call I you can think of
it as the integral solutions and then we
have a convex relaxation we have a
polytope I which is a converse
relaxation for the constraints and we
can think of the polytope as fractional
solutions now it's easy to see that the
polytope is done monotone that is if we
have if we have one solution which is
feasible and then we decrease some
coordinates from the solution then also
we'll get a feasible solution because we
want to scatter less and then we can see
also that the polytope is solvable is
like a collection of linear constraints
and we can optimize linear functions
over the polytope and then we we
introduce taking a random sample so we
have some fractional solution X and tag
and on sample R of X is essentially what
was at the lecture before so for every
for every item for every task we take it
to the random sample independently at
random with probability X I
and then we have motley in our extension
that has also been defined before we
have the sub-module objective function
which is defined on the integral points
and we want to extend it so that is
defined on the whole polytope P I and on
the on the whole hypercube 0 1 to the
enth and we defined it by taking the
expected value of the value of the
sub-module objective function on the
random sample
the formula here is slightly different
but that's exactly what is that the same
as what what what has been defined
previously
now we define a contractionary solution
scheme for some constant B and C at BC
balance contention Alice resolution
scheme is the procedure that for every
fractional solution which is taken from
the polytope I and rounded down by a
factor of B and for any subset I it
returns a random set satisfying the
following the first condition says that
the with probability 1 hours this set
will be a feasible integral solution and
also for all the tasks the probability
that a task has been selected to our
random set if it is in the random sample
is at least C where here the probability
is over both taking the random sample
and then taking the subset PI from the
random sample and we can just observe
that the we already have the balance
contraction resolution scheme it's
exactly our LP rounding algorithm
because in the selection phase we took a
random sample of this and in the
alternation faced every task every so
every task that has been selected is
accepted with probability at with one at
least one half so that gives us balanced
contractionary solution scheme with
start parameters
okay
I don't know if he's clear
so essentially our our IP routing just
gives us for free the contention of a
solution scheme first we do selection
and then with the alternation that's the
two parameters which we get and then
there's a theorem by tracker even
dragons inclusion saying that if we have
a submodular function and if we have a
family of feasible solutions and we have
a polytope which is down monotone and
solvable and if we have a bt balance
contention or a solution scheme then
there's a polynomial time randomized
algorithm that construct a solution
which is feasible solid the expected
value of the solution is at most theta
of the parameters bc times the maximum
value of the multi linear extension
within the polytope so how what do we
get here we know that we have the
balanced
contractionary solution scheme we know
that the maximum of this function f is
out the of the order of opt how do we
get it because if we have polynomially
bounded at capacities then the optimal
solution belongs to the polytope so this
value is at least as large as the
maximum right integral value that is
it's at least optimum and if we don't
have polynomially bounded property then
we have shown that's the optimal
integral solution here
that that that within the polytope we
still have a solution which is only by a
constant fraction worse than the optimal
solution so we we know that this value
is at least of the order of opt and that
gives us K log and approximation for
that gives us K approximation for
intersecting instances which gives us K
log and approximation for arbitrary
instances
[Applause]
[Music]
unweighted meaning that the profit is
just likely in our functions I mean the
number of tasks I know that for the pot
problem that it's constant but we don't
know the integral diggity yeah I mean
here one thing which will definitely
lose is at the beginning before we even
around the LP we have to partition our
instance into intersecting instances so
that's essentially where we where we
just lost Logan at the beginning for
intersecting instances I think here in
this static I think obelisk I because we
tasks can can be active on on K paths
and then we essentially do independently
at each these paths so I think you will
hear we will okay I would have to think
if we can do something smarter in this
case for the power
it is only a recap
I mean device on therapy
maybe you don't need to lose a login for
the for the intersecting instances when
we have a path than Caillou close one
because a pop has passed one waited for
now this approach doesn't give us
anything better but I don't know if it
can be modified somehow it's thank you